plates char's shells they carry things
we hold air like books a mum's cooking
or just simply beauty to me a study and
function are two parts of the equation
that I design a must resolve good design
is where Beauty purpose and function
intersect designed us anything that has
to happen to transform reality into
something we imagine that whether it's a
system of business or a product
a table manners are believed in design
and in providing value to the guests
anything down from collateral to the
environment to the guest experience has
all been carefully crafted so that they
have a good time at table manners
designers help us differentiate
ourselves from the mass of the FMV
outlet is given us for a strong identity
as consumers today becomes severe they
expect better user experience a lot of
time and resources goes into developing
products and good design ensures that
the product is a higher chance of
success so we become crucial for
businesses to focus on design to create
better user experience the challenges
here is a very restricted space with low
ceiling and no natural light what we
want to create is urban oasis right in
the middle of centenary so the idea was
actually to kind of create that linkage
to nature via unconventional landscape
methods like using green walls in a wish
in replace of potted plants and trees to
kind of bring that very lush greenery in
the heart of the spa design has helped
me to create the right ambiance and
experience for our customers without
compromising the
and productivity
IC design as a tool that can improve in
almost any aspect of their life from
rethinking public spaces to product
design to furniture design Singapore
Council has been very helpful by
introducing designers and studios into
companies so they can experience what
design is and how we can help people of
their business they actually brought an
idea which I thought was actually quite
a random crazy idea come to life when
design Singapore heard about it they
actually came on board with all kinds of
resources not just financial but they
also assisted us with any kind of
resources we need to make this happen
with this new design we have a
competitive edge within the industry and
it has really helped reduce costs and
improve efficiency
design singapore's encouraged us to take
progressive steps in improving and
innovating new solutions for businesses
and stakeholders for example in this
shop we incorporated the theme about
living kitchen incorporating between
like a living room and the kitchen and
how we can fuse it together and create a
space that the customers can come and
socialize and enjoy our food with the
grants that design Singapore puts out it
allows the clients to now have a more
comprehensive team or four consultants
now you can also have brandon's you can
have communications you can have
packaging and different aspects of the
possession dolls are put together
designed for from the start of the
project so the Emperor is a much more
cohesive and much more in depth in terms
of these
resolution
both of my overseas trade show are
supported by the design Singapore
council grant whenever people talk about
fashion you think of Paris London New
York but actually Korean designers
Chinese designers and hi designers have
become quite prominent so it's actually
a fantastic time for Singapore for the
metal Asian designers at this time cause
the whole world is looking our direction
or creating realistic imprinted
economies higher value innovative
solutions for major issues how to
improving our urban lifestyle and living
condition and so on good designs I must
consider cultural perspectives emotions
and practical needs is not about just
looking good sometimes design that she
helps to improve lives it should be
beautiful without compromising on the
way we go about in life design to me is
creating a unique experience designs
about creating something that matters to
someone design is a way of life
design transforms lives
you